I love that stuff like that they're like
comedians like they don't want a real
job contractors oh yeah no the gate guy
that's on a guy that this guy that guy
they all got their little [ __ ] and then
the handyman guys well I grew up with
those guys because I my dad was an
architect so I did construction from the
time I was in high school all throughout
the summer I was always doing side jobs
always had jobs on construction sites as
a laborer carpenters assistants I was
always around those guys I tried to do
that I lasted eight days I just with my
[ __ ] fair skin we were doing roofing
in July and it was just I just remember
my job was I was putting in the scaffold
and going around you know when you
[ __ ] drill the hole then you put the
triangle thing and then you [ __ ] put
the bolt on yeah Irish guy I kept going
Billy you must look quicker you much
more quickly isn't he kept saying to me
and I finally stuck my head out the side
of the house I was like dude I've done
this for three days if you want me to
[ __ ] go quicker you know when we
would like literally three stories up
and he finally shut the [ __ ] up he must
be a non-union guy
oh yeah dude I remember there was a
[ __ ] guy on the site I swear to god
he were the same [ __ ] jeans everyday
with like no underwear right I had a
[ __ ] giant [ __ ] hole right here on
his thigh so I'm in [ __ ] working in
the house and I just remember he stepped
over something with this left leg and
the whole [ __ ] hole moved right just
like flashed his [ __ ] junk I was just
like and I didn't know how to stand up
to people and plus else you know I was
the new guy on the thing and I just was
wanting to be like buddy how about you
put on some [ __ ] boxers or something
so I don't get a look at your [ __ ]
jaw first of all he's walking around
like a goddamn nail gun not like boxers
could stop that but any extra layer of
clothing that you could have this guy's
literally like his [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
like an owl looking out of a tree and
it's burned into my head I could pick
his junk out of a lineup that was the
first time I ever encountered alcoholics
I didn't really know about alcoholics so
I started working on job sites I
realized there was guys that just had a
drink they drink at lunch they were
drinking all the time they were always
trying to quit I remember one guy is
like I'm quit and I'm done
thinking that's good you can'tyou [ __ ]
together you know I was 15
it's like oh that's awesome yeah two
weeks later [ __ ] can of beer on the
job I was like oh I just remember I
could yeah I couldn't eat enough
I wasn't always hungry I was I packed
two sandwiches three sandwiches and he
did you spike you were the most wanted
yeah that's people used to do know those
who would like like those guys I mean I
I would come home like I was like I went
to football practice it was just it just
yeah I I if I stuck around for another
month I could have got in construction
workers shape I was but I just sucked at
it